The search for sustainable development becomes
the search for an adequate mode
of civilization
in the twenty-first
century. At the center of the idea of sustainability,
I think, is an ethical
imperative
to pass on an undiminished future
to our children.
Well, no one is smart enough or can know enough
to predict
the future,
so if prediction is not a possibility,
then how can we make progress
in thinking about
our options, in thinking about our future
in an organized manner?
And this is where scenario analysis comes
in.
When we discuss scenarios,
we talk about three broad channels
radiating out into the future.
One we call conventional worlds--
basically an evolutionary sequence of
events, despite hiccups like the current meltdown--
that the basic paradigm
and values
persist into the future.
The second channel is barbarization, which is--
markets and policies are unable to cope with
the
crises
and the chaos and the social disruption and the environmental
deterioration that is induced by
conventional worlds.
And you have futures of catastrophic disruption.
And the third we call great transitions,
where people rise to the
possibilities, to the promise of this planetary
phase with new values and new institutions
and steer-- in developing, steers toward
a more fortunate form of civilization.
Two necessary
conditions
that must evolve
to reach a civilization worth living in.
Over the next ten years, we will see a wave
of engagement,
and action,
of the citizens
of the world.
I think the-- what I call, for shorthand,
a global citizens movement,
is the necessary condition, the
necessary change agent,
for a
turning
away
from catastrophe, away from the abyss,
toward
Earthland,
this great transition future.
I think that the
upsurge in civil society that we are seeing
now, and have seen for the last twenty years,
is a glimpse of what could
occur.
But that civil society
ferment
is limited today
by fragmentation,
by lack of a shared
vision of the possible.
And I think this global citizens movement
is ready to be born, I think it's latent--
I think it could be brought to life.
So that was the first area. I think the second area
is this:
away from consumers and individualism and
the domination of nature and
more towards questions of
the quality of life
and the
ecological sensibility and human solidarity--
that would also be the second
pillar
that would signal that a shift
towards a great transition is possible.
I think if we get to this livable future,
it will be because humanity has found a way
to balance
the imperatives
of global responsibility
with diversity
and pluralism
and modes of culture
and development.
When we take our trips to outer space,
and we look back, we see an
integral
blue planet.
You don't see imaginary lines of states.
And so that this globalism, this sense
of the earth as a natural unit
for a human
organization and identity--
in some ways more profound
than
are the imaginary boundaries of
of nation-state. When we look at the question
of value change that could undergird
this great transition,
I think we have to look at
the process of change in
two arenas: one in affluent countries
and one in developing countries.
In affluent countries, we're already seeing
the precursors, the questioning of the meaning
of the good life.
Turning towards questions about the
quality of existence, not just the quantity
of
things as defining success
and well-being.
So,
that's one area-- is
a value change, is in terms of
what it is to be a whole person and a fulfilled person.
I think when we come to the question of the
developing world, there's an even more profound
transition
that we can imagine.
To begin to define their own agenda for
development,
that there are plural paths to modernity, not
a single path,
and that their own paths can leapfrog a lot
of the mistakes
that have gone on in the industrialized
world,
and begin to come up
with forms and models of development that
build on local traditions and customs
and culture.
Another area comes to
the question of the environment.
People, I think, are coming to see that the
rapaciousness of the past
must give way
to a sense of humanity's place
in the web of life.
And dependence on its
health, sustainability,
and bounty. So this is a major, almost Copernican
shift in awareness.
Copernicus
taught us
that we didn't live at the center of the universe,
but that we were on a
planet that revolved around the sun.
Well, this new Copernican revolution,
I think, is telling us that we are not at the
center of
Earth; we our part of the web
of life of this grand ecology,
and if we don't take care to see our place
within it,
then we may go down with it.
I think there are three
major areas
that we need to
move down
to begin this transition.
And those areas, I think, are understanding,
vision,
and action.
I think we need
to gain a better grasp
of this world we live in
and this emergent global system,
both as scientists
and as citizens.
We need to struggle,
to expand our mental maps
to traverse over space to take into account
a global panorama.
To span over time, to think over many decades,
where people from all over the world can
find their place within this broad umbrella
that unifies their various concerns
into
a broad-based process of awareness-building
and political change
that can actually begin
to steer things in a fundamentally different
direction.
So when we do reach our time of troubles-- which
well could come-- a time of systemic global crises,
that there is the political space and possibility
for recovery-- more than recovery
For building
and beginning
a new history.